so it's a big day of course it's huge
for uh
for england 50 55 years it's a long time
but it's also a huge day for italy the
fans
at home in italy they waiting for
winning tonight for sure
so it's great for us to love football
and
wherever you are from in the in the
world you will see this game
how they feel i think they are
rather calm i think they're doing the
same routines as they
always did the the whole tournament and
before that as well
i don't think they do anything different
in preparation team talks or whatever it
is i think england
whatever happens tonight i i think they
will win but whatever
ever happens they have done a great
great tournament they have played
most of the games very good football
they are very solid they're defending
very well
and you they have a lot of young players
for the future
i think they will win but touchwood
if not they have been doing great so
i don't think they will be criticized
negatively
that would be awful whatever happens of
course they have a lot to lose but
they are so close and they want to win
it but in in another way they should go
out
enjoy the match and doing what they
normally do
that southgate has has been doing great
with england and you see the result a
final
final in europe fantastic you have
sancho you have grayleys who could play
you have
rashford it's just to
choose who is in the best shape and
there saltgate is very very lucky he has
a lot of
good football players young hungry with
pace with technique
on the bench and that's great i think
also that
england they have a better bench than
italy have
the teams are both very good but the
bench
england is much better i will see the
game
uh at home in sweden uh together with
my children and
i i don't want to go to a pub or
to see it with a lot of people i want to
see it and to be
rather concentrated i normally don't
talk to anyone when it's
a game like this